Oscar nominees were announced that's
exciting I'm just not really I'm just
saying it but blogs and film experts are
everyone's trying to predict the winner
yeah
everybody's trying to brake the winner
really there are only two people who
know for sure who's gonna win they see
every movie and they're the most in
touch with the Oscar voting bloc
please welcome to predict the 2020 Oscar
winners via FaceTime everyone's parents
[Applause]
good good to talk to you everyone's
parents so the Oscars who do you think
will be on the winners list just curious
oh well Conan I love that one actor she
was in the the was the name of the movie
that I liked it was oh the wedding book
wedding book no no marriage story oh I
loved it he fell asleep too much talking
come okay but the actress in that honey
what was her name Jamie every time she
talks you you feel like she's about to
throw a glass of wine laura dern water
okay everyone's parents anything you
feel got snubbed we saw that movie
hustlers and it was interesting I don't
want to offend my liberal daughter who
lives in San Francisco but there was a
lot too much skin for me man yeah but I
love that pretty asian woman can I say
that Asian can I say Asian the items
anyway he fell asleep yeah okay the
theater was too warm of course okay
hey don't you one you know what should
have been nominated the uncut gems no
[Music]
[Applause]
you wouldn't like it
a lot of things Adam Sandler's in it so
Oh No thank you he's cool okay all right
so for the big one who do you think will
win Best Picture
well we saw the one about nice Hitler
okay Jojo rabbit yeah yeah and we saw
the one about the sad man who likes he
does makeup a joker yeah that's the one
about the Irish man it's called the
Irish man and we also saw in 1917 you
know it was good and you know a Conan my
grandfather fought in the World War one
no no no he didn't that was great uncle
Harold no no Harold wore glasses and he
couldn't get in you're thinking of
Joseph Harold's brother no us Joanna you
find it you guys guys come on move this
along what's your pick for best film our
favorite movie this year
hands down forest
now it's great movie but it came out 20
years ago yeah but it's on all the time
yeah just keeps getting better yeah oh
and that Tom Hanks so handsome I just
let him go to town on me hey I can't
blame her I mean ease erdan okay that's
all right thank you too much the Oscar
predictions
[Applause]